alors face à cette situation qui perdure
et qui devient des plus pesant de voyant
comment les habitants la capitale tokyo
réagissent plus de quinze jours après le
début de la catastrophe
reportage stéphanie perez et mathias
second en temps ordinaire c'est l'un des
quartiers les plus animés de tokyo celui
du marché aux poissons
mais aujourd'hui les vendeurs se sentent
bien seuls les clients boudent les étals
de poissons frais et les restaurants à
sushis
la faute au taux élevé de radioactivité
enregistré au large de fukushima
madame mes goûts s'attend à ce que la
crise dure longtemps
normalement j'ai 600 clients par j et en
ce moment j'en ai seulement une centaine
les japonais ne viennent plus et les
touristes ont annulé leurs vacances
pourtant on leur dit bien que nos
poissons ne proviennent plus de
fukushima maintenant on le fait venir du
sud du japon et de l'étranger étrange
ambiance à tokyo en apparence la vie a
repris son cours tout doucement mais la
centrale de fukushima à 250 km d'ici et
dans tous les esprits même au restaurant
ces légumes viennent de nagano pas de
fukushima pas de problème pour la santé
ce restaurateur français a perdu 50 % de
sa clientèle depuis la catastrophe et
ceux qui viennent malgré tout demande à
être rassuré certains légumes contaminés
ont été interdits à la vente
ces derniers jours si je mange des
légumes je veux savoir d'où ils viennent
mais j'essaie d'en manger le moins
possible je suis un peu inquiète on ne
sait pas quand cette catastrophe va
s'arrêter en plus les informations qu'on
nous donne change tous les jours on ne
sait pas si le gouvernement nous dit
toute la vérité
il ya une petite part à dos quand même
s'ils ont des faux sur les légumes là
aussi très important de l'expliquer que
l'eau est filtrée l'eau du robinet c'est
le problème des jeunes parents car à
plusieurs reprises cette semaine les
autorités ont recommandé de ne pas
l'utiliser pour les bébés
on donne seulement de l'eau minérale à
notre fille de 1 an même pour faire
cuire le riz ou la soupe
je mentirais si je disais que je n'ai
pas peur mais on n'a pas le choix
les habitants de tokyo ne cède pas à la
panique et il n'oublie pas les milliers
de sinistrés dans le nord du pays
ils collectent des fonds chaque jour des
japonais savent que c'est ensemble
qu'ils aideront leurs pays à se relever